we're reaching the stanley cup final
sports director chris matthews
leads off our coverage from the fortress
it was certainly loud
there earlier i can't believe you stayed
so focused chris very impressive
well thank you very much yeah they got
the music playing it's not as loud as it
was back then but i'll tell you what
this is going to be rocking tonight
don't forget 6 15 puck drop tonight an
early start
6 15. you want to avoid the traffic i
understand there are some
traffic problems out there coming from
summerlin so if you are attending the
game tonight
plan accordingly because it is about a 6
15 puck drop this evening
hey this is going to be an exciting
series it already has been through four
games
now it's the best of three who could win
those final two games remember the last
two games have been decided in overtime
by a single goal that's how tight
this series is of course a lot of the
talk also about the power play the gold
knights have just struggled on the power
play
montreal has gone 11 straight games
with a power play goal that is the
longest for the montreal canadian since
way way back in the 1933-34
season so it's been quite a while this
has been a real fun series
i want to point one thing out here if
you look over my right shoulder way up
top there by the
the castle you can see of the 31 flags
that used to hang
along the top of the fortress here now
there are just four the vegas golden
knights the montreal canadiens
to the left of that you see the
lightning and the new york islanders
that series now the lightning tampa
based on top three games to two
so it's all down to the final four when
you think about it vegas golden knights
in just four years of existence they are
just two wins away
from getting back to the stanley cup
final so lots of cool things happening
here
and the big tuck of course today was
marc-andre fleur it looks like he's
going to get the start in goal
he was the first one off the ice robin
leonard stayed on the ice a little bit
longer to get some extra work in so all
indications you know hockey is
full of traditions that first one off
the ice in the morning skate
is usually the starter in net so it
looks like mark andre flurry i might
mention also they got the uh
the flags or the the towels the rally
towels and our rally towel
tonight is going to be uh nick holden
number 22 the defenseman so
he's on the rally towel tonight as more
than 18
000 fans will be in here this is just
exciting game
five who wins this one is a win away
from advancing
to the stanley cup final vegas gold
knights just six wins away from hoisting
that cup
and partying down the las vegas strip if
they can just win
six more games anyway that's what's
going on here let's go outside now the
plaza kevin martin is out there with
some of these medieval maniacs who are
excited
about this big game five kevin
well hey chris thanks very much and yeah
excitement is an
understatement and i think i found a
really
neat dynamic check this out kurt and
john
a habs fan and a golden knights fan they
actually
just met and they are going into the
game together how cool is that
and kurt this will be your first game
inside t-mobile arena washington game
you've probably seen the atmosphere
on tv what are you expecting game five
to be like i'm really looking forward to
this this is
after being down the pandemic last year
seeing people back in here
i'm looking for not only the game
obviously hope we win but just seeing
people have fun that's gonna be awesome
and are you guys getting some weird
looks
as you walk by together being all buddy
buddy yeah we don't care about those
people
i love it that's awesome and john have
you recovered from the thrilling game
four win and what are you expecting to
play out for game five tonight
right now it's been a nail biter for
game four at game five
we're going to go down swinging the
goaltenders
both good at both sides but hey i want
the golden knights to come up on top
awesome well thank you guys so much have
fun in there and a lot of fun yes of
course
we're going to continue the coverage
coming up all
up till puck drop at six reporting live
outside a t-mobile arena kevin martin
eight sports now